[Musik]
mein name ist luca dilger in seinem
neuen blog ganz deutschland hallo
erstmal diese ist der titel einer
freunde ich stelle euch heute dinge vor
die ihr zu 100 prozent
oder sagen lieber 99 prozent war nicht
dass ich heute gesperrt sowie gar nicht
kennen ich stelle euch heute dinge vor
die ihr in eurer schulzeit gemacht habe
falls sie noch zur schule geht die ihr
vielleicht immer noch macht juli schlug
[Applaus]
freundin gerade hier zu hause sind
gerade sind sicher 31 grad
es ist gerade unglaublich heißt eben
wieder fällt ist weg gehe ich jetzt
erstmal eine runde schwimmen wieder
drinnen vom schwimmfreunde ran als
schwimmen im ozean thema fische
schnappen die great charts einfach nur
draußen julius zur schule gegangen ich
bin aus der schule gegangen und ich
glaube ca eigentlich 90 prozent aller
kinder noch mehr club handelt weil ich
das ist halle gegen deutschland zur
schule gegangen und in der schule geht
es nicht nur darum dass man aufpassen
gute noten schreibt darum sollte es
eigentlich gehen aber man macht auch
echt eine menge spaß sind sprach dass
die schule allerdings hat er auch eine
menge schwachsinn gemacht und
es gab auch immer so einige dinge die
wirklich schüler in nordrhein westfalen
den bayern bereich ich für mich du dich
gott es gibt ein paar typische dinge die
jeder schüler eigentlich gemacht hat und
da haben wir einen artikel im internet
index der einige dinge auflistet und
darauf werde ich heute mal reagieren
unschuldige 100 damen ist etwas was
glaube ich jeder erkennt uns war dass
wir man hat sich wie der entwerfer das
heißt entwerfen hat sich gefühlt als
würde man bei airbus oder boeing
arbeiten und gerade ein neues flugzeug
kreieren nur saß halt so aus und nicht
so die zweite sache die ich draußen so
habe die auch jeder hält ich weiß jetzt
jeder gemacht und ich gehöre nicht dazu
weil meine schulen mädchen sollte clean
bleiben allerdings hat man über all das
hier gesehen und die richtig krachen hat
da alles mögliche drauf stehen durften
sogar noch mitschüler der hdl
draufschreiben keine ahnung was ähnlich
gesagt fand ich das immer richtig doof
weil bei mir wollte halt nie etwas drauf
und auffällig müsse seine hp geraten
anfasst dann ist das überall tinte ja
ich bin täglich per so was die ganze
sache die ich besucht habe ist etwas was
glaube ich auch jeder kenne ich glaube
ich alle sachen glaube ich ihr das
glaubt dass jeder das kind heißen luca
wie heißt ihr schreibt mir die
kommentare das hier ist erstmal der flur
allerdings was ich damit sagen möchte
ist dass immer wenn man in serie gehen
muss das mal so ein zweiter mann hat
gesagt ich klopfe du redest immer außer
ich denn ich musste immer allein da
hinlaufen und alleine klopfen und
alleine reden weil ich ja keine freunde
hatte das hier kennen glaube ich auch
jeder das war diese college blöcke die
einfach nur dazu da waren sie voll zu
malen immer wenn einem langweilig war
hat man einfach komisch burg voll
gemacht die fünfte seite die ich raus
gesucht habe die ich auch nie gemacht
habe ich war glaube ich echt ein ganz
besonderes kind das hier einfach das
radiergummi penetrieren du hast sechs
freunde hat auch etwas mit landesweiter
zu tun so gibt es ja eigentlich nahezu
jeder verkauf der mit lehrerzimmer und
zwar hat man eigentlich immer vom
college block diese reste von einer
seite ab gemacht und dann irgendwie
zusammen gefummelt als wenn man den
neuen kohleblock hatte
man mit dem wetter abgerissen hat sie
nie direkt ab gemacht also so war es bei
mir aber es war nicht irgendein wunder
sich dann beispielsweise 30 blätter
abgerissen beim college block sondern
auch zu klappen weil da so ein dickes
fell so ganz ganz dick war die kleine
pizzen oder wenn wir mal alle abgerissen
dabei ist diese spirale kaputt gegangen
hat man halt so was damit gemacht ja
eigentlich und das alles nur weil er
fakten aus der schule allerdings hat
noch mal sieben etwas mit dem schulbus
zu tun und zwar dass wir waren immer die
beliebtesten plätze ich weiß nicht warum
ich so cool war hinten zu sitzen aber
ihnen wie was cool
vielleicht hat man sich gefühlt wie in
seiner limousine ich weiß woran es lag
also immer wenn die auf klassenfahrt
waren oder mit den lehrern irgendwo
hingefahren sind saßen die lehrer mal
ganz vorne
das heißt wenn man ganz hinten saß sagen
den lehrer am weitesten weg und man will
dass lehrer weit wechseln also ich
glaube das ist der grund warum die
coolen hinten sitzen diese folien kennt
jeder bei uns wird sogar vorgeschrieben
dass man mit dem fach hat eine bestimmte
farbe hat bei mir war es so dass roth
deutsch bargeld war englisch glauber
matte und grün war er kunde oder musik
früher auf der grundschule wodurch das
auf vorgeschrieben bzw wasserfarbe
hattet ihr also für mich war es immer so
eine richtige sitzt also ein bisschen
break fand einfach wenn ich gesehen habe
dass leute für englisch roth hatte
nämlich war hier wohl ich mach schluss
eine sache die man jetzt nicht unbedingt
direkt schon in der grundschule gemacht
hat wenn man das gerät
im unterricht benutzt hatte aber auch
der weiter finden wie beispielsweise
real studio gymnasium hauptschule
gesamtschule gibt es noch irgendeine
schulformen dass hier irgendwas in den
taschenrechner schreiben und dann auf
den kopf drehen und dann kam ein wort
raus war sogar so dass man nicht nur zum
angeben konnte die tasche recht und ich
bin jeden tag spricht dann kann man
nicht nur zahlen geben allerdings haben
wir auch vorziehen geschrieben wird
beispielsweise abb oder so kommt man
halt bei uns schreiben daher meine leute
aber geschrieben oder papa kommt man
beim schreiben oder mama bei der
nächsten sache weiß ich nicht mehr ganz
genau wie es heißt aber dass hier
es gab immer leute die diese komischen
bender dabei hatten konnten sich die
finger kontrolliert so umdrehen und dann
hatte man nie wieder frei und ich habe
nie so was und ich war etwas ganz
besonderes früher das hier auch jedes
kind früher gemacht ich glaube aber
weiter für den schulen nicht mehr so
aber dass man einfach sein ideal
genommen hatte dass ein geodreieck
irgendwo auf den tisch gepackt hat am 3
was auch immer hat einfach der mord was
auch jeder kennt ist das hier
wenn man mit dem finger geschrieben hat
und dann hält man den irgendwie falsch
alles voll mit tinte komme mir
allerdings zum nächsten schultag dem
wirklich jeder von euch kennen wird und
zwar wenn man so ein semester als neue
jahr gefeiert hatten die schüler kamen
hat man mindestens zehnmal immer das
hier gemacht
von 2015 2016 ging es noch einigermaßen
bei der 5 einmal dass man länger mal
2016 sind sehen naja man kann schwer aus
einer 67 macht und das hat so abgefangen
ich will nicht wissen wie viele blätter
ich an einigen sind darum verschwendet
habe alle leder jetzt bitte kurz
wegschauen aber das hier habe auch ich
gemacht ich weiß nicht wer auf die idee
kamen taschenrechner zu machen die man
auf klagen konnte mit so einer
schutzfolie wieder dahinter schieben
konnten wir wollen sich dort alles
reinschreiben
und ich meine das hier ist jetzt sogar
noch echt amateur bei uns hatte diese
hülle in den brennenden sonne blaues
papier eingeklebt mit so weißen
gebraucht hinweisen und so ein paar
formeln drin und so und leute haben das
einfach eingescannt und dann ganz viel
später dort aufgeschrieben in jener
schriftgröße 4 oder so die leute drauf
geklebt mit irgendwie doppelseitigem
klebeband und ada der perfekte später im
taschenrechner ich weiß nicht warum
lehrer das nie richtig kontrolliert
haben aber machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten fakt und zwar etwas was mich im
sportunterricht immer mehr kraft
aufgeregt hat das spiel was man am
meisten gespielt hat waffen und
völkerball ist der größte scheiß der
welt es gibt basketball hockey fußball
tel
das baseball alles es gibt klasse keine
sportarten und sie spielfeld dabei warum
sportlehrer bleiben wir direkt beim
sportunterricht freund ich glaube jeder
von euch kennt die bundesjugendspiele
also dass man diese bescheuerten
urkunden bekommen hat und vom land
weitwurf geübt hat und einfach nur
laufen und lange laufen und sprinten und
es ist so thum und langweilig immer
können sich nichts kaufen mit diesen
urkunden vom höchsten und wieder zu
einem typischen langeweile fakt dass der
schülerin zwar himmel hölle
also dieses komische mit dem hin und her
ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie es
funktioniert hat aber man hat es
gespielt früher der schönste moment
eines schülers ist einfach wenn der
lehrer mit so einem ding in den
klassenraum reinfährt denn dann wusste
man konnte einfach schlafen das hier
hatte man glaube ich auch immer in der
weihnachtszeit das schöne deko auf dem
tisch und dann hat man immer morgens zum
beispiel war es bei uns so immer wenn es
montag war und gerade und einen tag
vorher war irgendein hotel dann hat man
erst mal noch kurz gesungen und dann das
ist wird sich nicht voll komisch und das
ist mir gefallen da zu sehen ist aber
auch egal ich fand die stimmung auf
jeden fall ganz gut es war alles
megacool dekoriert und dort auf jeden
tag ein anderes plätzchen mitbringen und
kommt den hund aber auch schon zur
letzten seite sache nummer 20
da habe ich kein foto aber auch immerhin
jeder gesagt haben hey hausaufgaben dies
dies dies und lesen musste man einfach
lesen keine aufkommen
stelle dich jetzt allerdings auch diese
typischen schulte fakten dinge die er an
gegen weekend beenden weil die damen und
herren die sich an dieser stelle
deutlich den urlaub beenden
denn schule und ich fahren nun nach köln
wir sind zurück angekommen könnt ihr
seht schon es ist er mittlerweile dunkel
draußen ihr sollten man halt das licht
an
jetzt ist juli das im block bisher wenig
so block mäßiges passiert ist allerdings
lagen gehalt den ganzen tag irgendwie
nur draußen
wir liegen einfach den ganzen tag
draußen es war halt unfassbar gutes
wetter und sie waren bei meiner familie
und die haben pool und dafür auf
schwimmen
allerdings sind in einem der letzten
blocks mit dem rund unserer nachbarn
gassi gegangen und da habe ich mir
gedacht
wie geht's eigentlich meinem hund
also das springt er war scheiße von ihm
hoch wie lange soll das noch dauern drei
wochen später
[Musik]
wenn schon kein bock mehr glänzt sogar
da oben und meine damen und herren wir
können ich habe mich jetzt läuft auch du
kaputt was hast du da warst du warst du
ein stückchen wie kann er sich das so
krass freuen darüber viele wollten hat
mal wieder ein interner sehen hier in
den blogs weil alle gesehen haben dass
ich so eine tolle bindung zueinander
haben und dass das alles so küberl ist
das war toll ich mache mir gerade ein
kompliment hier und du bist du komm komm
du schaffst das
wir haben schon mit dem trainiert
das ist besser versucht das immer noch
mitzumachen
wir sind hier noch weiter ihr glück
versucht dann wird mir meine damen und
herren würde ich den blog an dieser
stelle jetzt allerdings auch beenden es
war kein typischer blog von wegen hey
wir machen diese machen darf sondern
mehr im schul dinge ich bin gerade so
gartemann t shirt es ist einfach nicht
so viel passiert ich habe um ehrlich zu
sein sehr viel steuerkreis erledigt und
das muss ja auch sein
mit dem in deutschland sein muss alles
geregelt sein ich hoffe euch hat diesen
blog hier heute trotzdem gefallen als
das getan hat was gerne mal einen leid
meine damen und herren ich bin ich
[Musik]